- I'd love to answer any questions
y'all have about anything.
Raise your hands.
Or probably raising your hand
is the best way to do it.
Yes, Kai, ask your question.
- All right, thanks.
Thanks again, Sal, for taking your time
and answering questions.
Super appreciate it.
My question revolves around a lot of like
things that my colleagues have brought up,
which is like dealing with burnout,
especially with like obviously last year
with the coronavirus and
even now with Delta variant
and like some quarantine and
some measures coming back in.
I think a lot of people, you know,
they're dealing with multiple
things outside of work,
but it affects their work
and their state of mind.
So what are some tips that you have
like dealing with burnout?
- Good question and excellent question.
Maybe the most important question.
And I think burnout is
one of these things.
I don't know how many,
I'm sure everyone here has experienced it
in some way, shape, or form.
But it creeps up on you.
You think you can handle it.
You think you can handle it
until you can't handle it anymore.
And then it's usually
too late to address it.
There's a couple of things
that I have done preventatively
that I have found have been
like life-changing for me.
I meditate regularly.
I remember when I was younger.
I was intrigued by this
idea of meditation.
It seemed very mystical and very powerful.
But I remember when I tried
it when I was a teenager.
I was like, you just sit
quietly for 10 minutes,
20 minutes, 30 minutes.
How does that work?
And in hindsight, I think I
just had an overactive mind
and I couldn't even imagine what it meant
to have a still mind.
Fast forward until about five years ago,
I'm in my late 30s at this point,
and I realized that I
was approaching a burnout
on a lot of levels.
I'd kind of spread myself too thin.
I was having to do a
lot of travel for work.
I never enjoyed planes
and I'm starting to get
claustrophobic on the planes.
I was like, okay, something's going.
And that's when I rediscovered meditation.
And I think it's one of those things
and if possible, folks can
mute their microphones.
I hear some background noise.
Is that it's a very subtle
but very powerful thing.
I read a lot of these gurus
who speak about meditation,
instilling the mind.
And our minds naturally gravitate
to the very obvious things.
The things that really
hit our senses hard,
but our emotional state
and our mental state
is a very subtle thing.
But what I can guarantee
to almost everyone here
is if you do sit down for
that even five or 10 minutes,
but I find it really starts to kick in
at around 30 or 40 minutes.
And you just have faith that
it's going to be good for you,
that it will be.
And there's even going to be those days
where your mind is wandering
and there's noise outside.
And you're like, oh, this
isn't a good meditation.
Even that, I find after 20 or 30 minutes
makes a big, big difference.
Also, the perspective that you take to it,
I think some of us, myself,
when I first tried to do this, I was like,
I wanted to be the perfect meditator
and I wanted perfect conditions
and I'd want silence.
And I found myself getting
stressed about the meditation.
I would like yell at my kids,
"Be quiet, I'm meditating!"
And I realized at some point
that's completely the
wrong way to approach it.
The way to approach it
is to accept everything
and to observe everything
and to just try to be still
and to be curious and have
a sense of humor about it.
And then when you do it that way,
I find it very energetic.
So that's my biggest life hack.
Outside of that, just really make sure
that you have time for
yourself and your family.
I just talked about meditation.
For some people, it might be exercise,
it might be socializing.
But you can't under invest in that.
That's something that I've
learned over the years.
That we have a culture that idolizes work,
and that has certain
positive aspects of it.
But we're here to live our lives as well.
So that's my best advice.
Stay socially connected, meditate,
and make sure you have time
and space for yourself.
It's not going to be.
Someone told me the saying,
"If you don't have the time
to meditate for an hour,
you should meditate for two." (laughs)
And I also found the other
way that when I meditate,
it's always a good use of time.
Like part of my brain says,
oh, I don't have 10 minutes.
Really, you don't have 10 minutes?
Then that's a problem, Sal.
If you don't have 10 minutes,
you need to slow down.
Let's see, so many questions.
I know I'm giving these super long.
I think Selena was next.
- Hi, Sal.
Thank you so much for this session.
I'm a high school junior at this moment,
and I'm in a situation
where it's very hard for me
to attend junior year in person.
And as I live in NYC, there
is no remote option as of now.
So I'm not really sure how
I should proceed with this.
And since I'm in a small Ivy school,
the courses in 11th grade and 12th grade
are two year courses.
So if I miss junior year, that
would be really problematic
because 12th grade curriculum is based on
what I learned in 11th grade.
And I feel that even in the scenario
where my teachers do provide
some guidance from home,
it would be really difficult
for me to perform well
or even effectively learn the content
as I'm having a different experience
from all my other classmates.
And I would really, really like to hear
your insight and advice on this.
Thank you.
- Yeah, first of all, thanks
for asking the questions, Selena.
It does sound like a tough situation.
My best advice, as you know, junior year,
it can be very important
year, especially now
as you're trying to think about
college and all of the rest.
I don't fully know all
of what you might have
or not have access to.
I do think the good news
is there are avenues
outside of the traditional that could,
you could still learn
a lot of the material
or most of the material
and prove what you know,
so that colleges and other folks
can take a serious look at it.
Many of y'all know that we've been talking
to universities about Schoolhouse.
University of Chicago
famously last year said,
hey, if you can certify your
knowledge on Schoolhouse
and then even better go on to
become a tutor on Schoolhouse,
we, Universe of Chicago,
are gonna take that
very seriously in the
college admissions process.
And they actually, I don't
know if this is public,
they had a very high admissions
rate for the 40 or so kids
who actually use Schoolhouse.world
as one of the main signals that they use.
Y'all will hear shortly about MIT,
is also doing something similar.
And we're talking, just yesterday,
I've talked to 30 admissions officers
at a bunch of universities
saying, hey, look,
there's an interesting signal here.
You don't wanna force everyone to do it,
but here's a mechanism where
at least in the subjects
that Schoolhouse has, we
can certify your knowledge
and then you can go on to become tutor.
I think that can be a very
powerful potential route,
especially because you can
leverage Schoolhouse.world
and Khan Academy to learn the material
and then certify yourself
and then hopefully even
become a tutor yourself.
I think that will speak very favorably
of how you are leveraging your junior year
above and beyond the things, you know,
all of your maths subjects that
I imagine you'd be covering.
Your science subjects,
including, you know,
we just lost Environmental Science
and we've always had things
like Econ on Khan Academy.
Between Khan Academy and Schoolhouse,
I think you can do a lot.
I think in your Humanities,
we wanna explore eventually
doing that in Schoolhouse.world.
We're not quite there.
There's some enrichment courses
where people are starting
to dabble in that.
But I would recommend, you know,
take a look at some of the MOOCs.
I think if you're able to
go into some of those MOOCs
and do well in them, especially
if you could leverage
Khan Academy for your STEM
and Schoolhouse for your STEM
and then use MOOCs for
some of the other courses,
whether it's the History
course or your English course,
whatever else.
And then also use the time to do well
on standardized tests,
on your SATs, whatever.
I think you're gonna have
a good junior year then.
And I gotta believe that when you go
next year into your senior year,
if next year you're going
to apply to college,
those colleges are going to take
your circumstances very seriously.
They definitely look at people who had
hard circumstances to deal with.
And they say, what did you do
with those hard circumstances?
And if you're able to surprise them
with what you're able to do
with those hard circumstances,
I think you're going to
be fully in the game.
And I think in some strange way,
having this time might end
up being a gift in some ways,
because you're going to explore things
that you might not have
otherwise had time for.
That's my best advice,
not fully knowing all
of your circumstances.
And I'll add what I had just said.
Also make sure you don't burn
out, take care of yourself,
make sure you don't lose that
piece of the puzzle as well.
- Okay.
Sal, sorry about this.
Thank you for all the advice.
I wanted to ask another
question related to this,
because my parents are
actually considering
virtual high school as an option instead,
because I'm not really
sure if I can end up
either retaking junior
year or delaying it.
So I wanted to know if an
online high school diploma
would end up putting me at a disadvantage
in college admissions.
- I'm not an expert here.
I suspect and I think there's
different online high schools.
I'm familiar with a few of them.
There's Stanford Online High School,
which is very highly reputed.
And I'm sure there's others like that.
I don't think you're at
a disadvantage at all
if you go to some of
these online high schools.
And on top of that,
if you're able to do
other interesting things,
I think you're going to
be very much in the game.
So yeah, I wouldn't worry
too much about that.
Thanks, Selena.
Let's see, I'm gonna go, let's see.
I think Zoom does it so
that whoever's furthest
to the right was the next person.
So Shivam, your question.
- Hi, Sal.
It's really a dream come true.
I am meeting you after so long.
- You need better dreams.
- Actually, just a little intro.
Like I have been using Khan
Academy since like grade six
and I have over one
million points on Khan.
- That's an achievement.
- Yeah.
Just award, like I have
perfected my maths through you.
I admire you so much.
So the thing is I want to ask
is I belong to a very small town
where there are not many good facilities.
So how do you think would I be able to,
do you think is it okay to dream big?
Like am I suitable for big universities?
Like students at the U.S. have like,
they do summer programs and all like that.
And I am from India and I don't
have that much facilities.
But yeah, I am a tutor at Schoolhouse,
and I really enjoy
that, tutoring students.
But yeah, the thing is
I sometimes feel that
am I really disadvantaged
with the students
who do such kind of programs,
who have done internships and all kinds,
all things like that?
- Yeah, so it's a great question.
And the way I think about
it and I have, you're right,
I'm sure you're in a circumstance
where you don't have all of the resources
that you would ideally have.
But one of the dreams of Schoolhouse.world
is that we can hopefully
reward folks like yourself
who are tutors and who are
doing really good at it
to connect them with opportunities
that might not otherwise have been there.
So I kind of view myself
as the guidance counselor
for all of the tutor community here
and say, like, how can I help
all of these people get opportunity?
Because if you really think about it,
for college or for jobs,
there are these huge complex processes
that you have to usually,
all these hoops you have to jump through.
But if you boil down to it,
and I've talked to other
people who hire people
as like, you show me someone who can,
who's a highly rated tutor
on Schoolhouse.world in Statistics.
I'm just picking Statistics,
could be other subjects.
Why wouldn't you hire that person?
That person clearly has analytical skills.
That person clearly can communicate.
That person clearly has empathy.
Here's a little secret.
In most jobs in the world,
if you have those things,
you're going to do very, very well.
Everything else you can learn.
And so my hope is that I can,
we collectively, not just myself,
can figure out ways to
connect you to opportunity.
What grade are you in right now?
What class are you in?
- 12th grade.
- You're in 12th?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Applying.
Looking to apply for U.S. colleges.
- Yeah, well, I think I just listed a few,
and obviously, none of these colleges
are "easy to get into," so to speak.
But expect to hear a few more.
And I think even the
colleges that aren't part
of our initial consortium, so to speak,
I think if you are a very active,
highly reputed tutor on Schoolhouse.world,
through the tutor community,
we wanna be able to help you.
Like, even if there's a college
that doesn't know about Schoolhouse.world,
if we can leverage what we know,
our notoriety to let them know, hey,
this is not a joke to become
a highly reputed tutor.
I would take this very seriously.
So then I think you would have,
I think you would have a fighting chance.
And I will say, even if it does,
if it does work out, awesome.
If it doesn't work out,
I think you're gonna have
multiple shots at gold.
So wherever you go to
college, there's always,
you can transfer or even
post-college graduate school
or your job, I hope over the
next three or four years,
Schoolhouse.world, being a
highly reputed tutor on it
becomes a major thing that a lot of people
are going to index on.
So that's my best advice.
- Okay, thank you.
Thanks a lot.
- No, thank you.
Thank you for being a tutor.
Let's see.
I'm not sure if this
is showing up in order.
I'm gonna go somewhat random-
- Hey, Sal, just a followup
on Shivam's question.
I have a four sisters in Afghanistan
who is there right now,
and then a lot of girls,
the situation being really dire.
I, myself, am working in
Facebook here, project's here.
So I've been really fortunate
to have your Khan Academy,
learning things from you
and then also your platform.
I was wondering how can
we expand that further
and then give the chance for the,
like a fighting chance for
the girls in Afghanistan
or other like countries where there's war,
or they don't have
facilities like in India
or elsewhere too.
How can they do that?
And how can they take
advantage of the situation,
especially when the schools,
when the system do not
allow you to go to schools
and that past sixth grade,
you cannot even attend if you're a woman.
So how can we use your platform
and then have those girls
like a fighting chance?
If you could maybe kindly answer to that.
- Yeah, wonderful question.
So, yeah, it's a big,
especially given what's going on now.
Some of y'all, I've
told this story before.
The case in point is very clear.
There's actually a young
girl named Sultana.
You could do a Google search for her.
Nicholas Kristof wrote an op-ed about her:
"Meet Sultana, the Taliban's Worst Fear."
He wrote this three or four years ago.
But it's exactly what you described
even before the current
circumstances in Afghanistan,
where when she entered sixth grade,
she wasn't allowed to go to school.
Her brothers were.
And then she luckily did
have an internet connection
and she was able to essentially
self-teach herself English.
She found out about Khan Academy.
That became her lifeline.
By the time she gets into high school,
she decides that she wants
to be a physics researcher,
a theoretical physicist.
She lies to her parents to go
to Pakistan to take the SAT.
She does unusually well.
Anyway, long story short,
Sultana was eventually able
to make it to the U.S. and is now doing
quantum computing research
at Tufts University.
And what I always remind folks is
for every Sultana we know
about who's able to do it,
how many more tens or hundreds
of thousands or millions might there be?
And what she had to do
to get there, none of us,
I don't think I would
have been able to do that
if I was given the same set of obstacles.
So she had unusual determination,
unusual resilience.
My hope is that Khan
Academy, Schoolhouse.world
can be that lifeline.
Now, it is predicated on internet access.
My understanding of what's
going on in the ground
in places like Afghanistan is that,
fingers crossed, they haven't
shut down internet access.
So if that's what we can depend on
that we can provide layers on top of that
that can at least give someone a lifeline.
And I could imagine,
Sultana went on her journey
before Schoolhouse.world existed.
But if Schoolhouse.world existed,
she is someone who I
very easily could imagine
would have been very
active in this community.
She would have certified her knowledge.
She would have used
the community to learn,
frankly, not just to
learn the subject matter,
but frankly, to learn the
language, to learn English.
And then she would have
gone on to become a tutor.
And just like Shivam's question,
I think she could have then used that
as a signal to people to say, look,
this is someone interesting
that we need to make
sure has opportunities.
So that's my best answer.
I wish there were things that we could do
more on the ground.
And I don't know, I don't know.
But our collective avenue here is,
the Khan Academy can make more resources,
but I think Schoolhouse.world can actually
be a very, very powerful
resource for these young girls.
If they just have an internet connection,
they can become part of this community.
And I'm hoping, my dream
for Schoolhouse.world
is between it and Khan
Academy can almost turn
into a safety net education
system for the world.
So that if you are going to
school with resources, awesome.
You use Khan Academy to
personalize and get even better
and use Schoolhouse for
supplemental tutoring
so you don't fall through the cracks.
But if you don't have a great school,
or if you have no school at all,
Khan Academy, Schoolhouse.world,
the certification,
the tutoring, you can get
to where you wanna go.
So that's my best answer for an actual
very unfortunate circumstances
the world is in right now.
- Thank you, Sal, for the answer.
And could they also use your Khan Lab
High School program to get admitted
and especially if the
schools have shut been down?
- Yeah, so good question.
So Khan Lab High School,
some of y'all might know,
I started a school Khan
Lab School seven years ago.
It's now K through 12.
There's a high school,
Khan Lab High School.
I'm always sensitive.
Everything has my name on it now,
but people assure me it's
good for branding (laughs).
I used to make fun of people
who named things after
themselves, but it shows you.
We are exploring doing
a virtual component.
The original spirit of the
vision of Khan Lab High School
is can we create a model
that then can be replicated everywhere?
Whether we replicated or
other people copy, awesome.
We are now realizing
there might be interest
in creating a virtual component
that leans on Khan Academy
and Schoolhouse.world,
but could also give people credit.
What I will say, going back
to Shivam's original question,
well, cause even Khan Lab school,
even for the students who
are going there in person,
it's a very non-traditional school.
It's mastery-based.
Kids have the opportunity
incentive to improve their grades.
We don't use letter grades.
We use a slightly
different form of grading,
but it's unusual.
So there's always the
question of these parents.
It's like, are these kids
even gonna get into college?
And what we have found
is in the U.S., at least,
the private schools are very flexible
and are very open to looking
at alternative things,
especially if they can make sense of them.
So that's where I think
the Schoolhouse.world
certification tutoring
could have a lot of value,
and we're seeing more and
more of the public schools
are also opening their aperture to it.
But you're right.
If Khan Lab High School or other partners,
we're talking to some
colleges that also might give
college credit for
certain types of mastery
on Khan Academy or Schoolhouse.world.
That also could be interesting.
So we wanna continue to explore that.
So let's see, next question, Renee.
I'm not sure if I'm going
in order, but I'll try to.
- Yeah, thank you, Sal.
And hi, everyone.
First, I just wanna thank you.
I used your Khan Academy many years ago,
and I was able to got into,
get into a really good university
and then get into my
PhD degree program here.
So I really just wanna thank you.
And then, so my question
here is how do you deal
with information overload?
How do you learn something?
Because every time you
search for something,
there are thousands of thousand stuff.
So how are you doing your
learning in this world?
- It's a great question.
I was once, I was giving a
talk in Spain two years ago.
It was the most poetic
introduction I had ever gotten.
But part of the
introduction was this notion
that the irony is when there's a flood,
that's when actually people
oftentimes die of dehydration
or experience dehydration
when there's a flood.
And the introducer, he
made the analogy is that
the same thing is happening
in information today.
There's a flood of
information, but we are still,
but a lot of it we can't
trust or it messes with us.
Even the news itself.
I know there's a huge issue globally,
but especially in the U.S.
about news being polarized.
And we're all in our own bubble.
But even if you assume
the news is not biased,
although everything has
some kind of a bias,
even if you assume it's not biased,
the news by its very
nature is taking a world
of seven or eight billion people
and telling you the seven worst things
that happened that day.
Like our brains aren't
good at processing that.
I wish they could tell us that,
because the same day that those seven
horrible things are happening,
there's probably 700,000 beautiful things
that happened that weren't "newsworthy."
And so it messes with your head
and messes with your brain.
So what I would say is
protect yourself from it.
I think future health
professionals are going to realize
that exposing yourself
to this type of thing
can become really harmful.
That doesn't mean put
your head in the sand.
I read the news, but I really
do try to be conscientious
of like, look, I can go to a website
and I can read a few headlines.
I got the essence of the news.
If I were to go on these 24-hour channels
or in social media,
I'm gonna start getting
all of these other things that
are all designed, frankly,
to get me worked up and I
don't wanna be worked up.
So I'm gonna go do my work.
But one foot in front of the
other, live my life, meditate.
Sometimes when I am experiencing
the information overload,
and it might not be from social media
or from the news.
It might be from work.
I'm constantly getting emails in.
I'm constantly, people are slacking me.
People are this.
There's 9, 10 decisions
that are coming to my desk every day.
And I can feel and I've become
more sensitive to saying,
hey, Sal, you're feeling kinda off.
You're not present right now.
Then I just try to stop what I'm doing
and even do a 10 minute meditation.
Just sit quietly or go for a walk.
I find is a great way to reset.
And then on top of that, make
sure you're getting exercise,
make sure you're eating well,
drinking a lot of water and sleeping well.
I do this stuff religiously.
So that's my best advice
for the information overload
or when you're feeling
angsty about the world,
just find a place of
stillness, a place of quiet,
and try to be careful on how
much that stuff sucks you in.
And I've been sucked in.
Some of the news that's
going on in the world,
like, oh, we should watch it.
I watch it, and it's like
you can't turn it off.
And like an hour goes
later and you're like,
I don't feel better right now.
And I learned the important news
within the first two minutes.
The rest of the 58
minutes just made me feel
kinda not so good.
Let me go do something else.
In terms of the question
of how do I learn,
I'm constantly just asking questions.
So I'm actually about
to make a middle school
science video on the atmosphere.
And some people on my team
sent me some standards
that we need to cover
and they're pretty basic,
but I'm like, okay, what
makes us interesting?
And I'm like, okay,
let me make sure that I can help explain
where does officially,
where does the atmosphere
end and space start?
Now we know it's not
like there's some line
where it actually does end.
It's a gradation.
But people have the Karman
line and they've defined it
as roughly 60 something miles.
And, okay, what are the
the lowest satellites?
Okay, it's about a hundred miles.
And I just keep asking these
questions of like, okay,
if something's in low earth orbit,
because it's still going
to have some atmosphere,
still going to run into a few nitrogen
and oxygen molecules every now and then,
it's gonna slowly slow down
and slowly come back to earth.
How long do they last?
So for me, it's just
asking these fun questions
over and over again,
and having that sense
of curiosity about it.
And then once I'm really jazzed
about whatever I'm about to do,
then I just press record and go.
But that's something pretty simple.
If something is more esoteric,
I'd like to talk to people about it.
I'll call up friends.
Another thing I like to
do when something is dense
or I'm trying to conceptually get it,
read it one day and say, okay,
my brain will process it.
I kind of delegate it
to my brain and my mind.
And I'm like, by tomorrow,
my mind will have insights about it.
Don't worry about it, conscious Sal.
Subconscious Sal has it covered.
And it's amazing that
it works, but it does.
I remember in college,
when I would take the
theoretical math classes,
sometimes you look at the
problem sets and you're like,
I can't make sense of any of this.
But you do it.
You at least try every problem.
You close the book, go to sleep.
In the morning, I can do like 80% of them.
I've done the same thing on tests,
where I'm taking this
test, these really deep,
theoretical math classes and
you see four or five questions.
And you're like, I don't know.
Let me just think about it.
But then I kinda get
into a meditative place.
And in about 20 minutes, I'm like, oh,
my subconscious is starting
to give me the answers.
I'm like, it's amazing what
the subconscious can do.
So anyway, that's other advice.
We're almost out of time.
Let me see, I'm sorry I couldn't get,
I'm giving you these long-winded answers.
Let's see.
Maybe Salil.
No, Salik, Salik, Salik K.
- Hello, Sal, it's great to meet you.
I am 12 years old and
currently being homeschooled.
And I'm also ahead of my class.
I (indistinct) starting school.
So I've been using the Khan
Academy platform since one year,
and I have about 1.5
million energy points on it.
- Another Shivam.
Go ahead, sorry I interrupted you.
- I'm sorry, it's all good.
And I finished grade eight, grade five.
Grade five and grade six
and finished grade seven and grade eight
and also finished all the JavaScript
on the Khan Academy platform
and now learning RCM
and looking forward to learning
all the other programming
languages available on
the Khan Academy platform.
So actually, I know it's a good,
very, very good future
ahead in programming.
So can you advise me
and advise me in this?
- Yeah.
- Since I'm from Pakistan
and it's past midnight here,
I'll take advantage and ask two questions,
if you don't mind.
So my second question is I
have a great taste in gaming.
Can I build a future out of it?
- Yeah, well, first of all, Salik,
I have no doubt.
I mean, don't get over-confident,
but I have no doubt that
you're gonna do very well.
And I'll make my plug
'cause I have you now
before anyone else is
asking for donations.
When you become a billionaire,
a founder of a gaming company,
remember how much of that
was due to Khan Academy.
And, you know, 10% maybe?
I'm kidding (laughs).
- I will thank you my whole life.
(laughs)
- Look, I'm only half joking.
But to your point, yeah.
Look, if you love coding and
you're the exact same age
as my oldest son, you'll
probably get along.
He's also really into
coding and all of the rest.
Keep doing it.
And I would say keep building things.
Keep progressing academically.
And I have no doubt that, and
your question about gaming,
yeah, I only think
that's only gonna become
a bigger and bigger industry,
both in the gaming industry in particular.
And look, you look at companies
like Minecraft and Roblox.
I mean, these are massive things.
And in the next 10 or 15
years, there's gonna be things
that are a whole order of
magnitude, even bigger.
So I think there's unlimited
work to be done there.
And also, I think every other industry
is thinking about how do they automate
and leverage technology more,
and then how do they gamify more?
Something we think a
lot about Khan Academy
is how do we make better game mechanics
so that we can addict
the Saliks of the world
into learning and all of this.
So, yeah, you're gonna keep
doing what you're doing.
Remembering my answers to the
other one, don't burn out.
Don't put too much pressure on yourself.
Make sure you, you know, if you can,
when my children were first born,
I was a little bit of
a tiger dad thinking,
oh, if they can master
their subject matter,
if they can build some
of these hard skills,
they're gonna be fine.
And there is some truth to that.
Obviously, every parent
wants their children
to be able to support
themselves, support their family,
have a healthy, productive life.
But as I've grown, I realized,
yes, that's important.
But the most important thing is having
kind of a mental, emotional resilience.
And that's where my first advice to Kai
around the meditation and
making time for yourself
and having a good social network.
Incredibly, incredibly important.
If you have the combination
of those two things,
you really are gonna be unstoppable
because everyone's journey is gonna have
some high points and you're gonna get,
I have more low points
than y'all might imagine.
And I've definitely had them over my life.
But it's that ability to
kind of detach yourself
from your ego sometimes,
to not get too worked
up about some things,
have some tools at your
disposal to meditate,
to exercise, to whatever it is.
For some folks, it might be religion.
But it takes you into
that meditative place.
I think that'll make you
incredibly resilient.
So if you've got the skills
and you've got the resilience,
you're gonna be unstoppable.
So that's my best advice there.
Maybe time for one more.
I know we're over, but
I'm having a good time.
Daisy.
I'm somewhat randomly picking.
- Hi, Sal.
So first, I just wanna say thank you
for all that you have done to enrich
the educational experiences
of learners on Khan Academy
and now Schoolhouse.
So I, myself, I'm a tutor at Schoolhouse
and I'm sort of constantly
looking for ways
that I can more effectively
like present or teach concepts.
And so I'm sort of just wondering,
do you have any tutoring
strategies or tips
that you like to use and
has there perhaps been
someone like a teacher
who's teaching style
you really admire and who
has been an inspiration
to you as an educator?
Thanks.
- Oh, a good question.
Not that I have fully figured it out.
I think there's two modes that I get into.
One is the explaining mode.
And that's the one that many of you all
might be familiar with on Khan Academy.
And when I'm in explaining mode,
that's where I try not to script it.
I try not to over plan it.
I do try to make sure that I am excited
about what I'm about to do,
because I always tell anyone teaching,
if you're not excited about it,
there's no way that your students
are gonna be excited about it.
I also try to not be stressed about it
because stress, humans are very good
at sensing stress in other people.
And for most learners,
it's already a slightly
stressful experience
or maybe a very stressful experience.
And then if the teacher is stressed,
that's only gonna make the
student even more stressed.
So I like to,
even though you don't see my
faces on Khan Academy videos,
I actually do force myself to
smile no matter what happen.
My car might've gotten
towed, whatever else,
but I'll force myself to smile.
Before making the video,
I force myself to just kind of relax.
If I'm not relaxed, I
will take a little bit
of a one minute, two minute breather,
just get into a good place,
'cause it's gonna show up.
And then really trying
to focus on the intuition
and the ahas and let your
personality shine as much as,
whatever your personality is.
I think when you show that
authenticity, you really connect.
And then when I imagine
who I'm speaking to,
I really just try to speak
to almost like a younger,
not even a younger,
just a version of myself
that just has not learned
this material yet.
But I try to respect that,
okay, they are also curious.
They also wanna connect the dots.
I don't try to talk down to them
or I don't try to talk above them.
So that's that.
Now the other mode is the
Schoolhouse.world mode.
When you're actually with people
like we are now, tutoring,
that's where I just keep
trying to remind myself,
the more that I can be a question asker,
and it can be directed
questions, the better.
And I've had trouble sometimes
with awkward silence.
Like even at dinner parties,
I'm always the guy that like,
when there's like three
seconds of awkward silence,
I'm trying to fill it in somehow (laughs).
Like who saw the game last night?
One of my things that I need to work on
is being more comfortable
with that awkward silence.
And also, when you're tutoring folks,
you ask a question.
People might not have
an answer immediately,
but make sure they have
some space to do it,
or give them context,
like the message board,
where it's like, hey
everyone, put what you think.
That might feel a little bit safer
if someone's a little
bit more introverted.
I think try to pull
people out of the screen
as much as possible.
In Schoolhouse.world, make them feel safe.
But say, hey, you know.
Call on them a little bit.
What do you think?
How would you approach this problem?
But I think the more that
you can make them do the work
and you're pulling it out of them,
I think that's going to be
a really good experience.
And you just bring this
joy and energy to it.
I think it's gonna be quite wonderful.
- Thank you so much.
- All right, all right.
This is super, okay,
I'll do two more quick questions.
I'll do two questions and I will go to,
let's go to Jose and Sarah.
Apologies to everyone else.
Apologies to everyone.
Jose and then Sarah.
- Hi, Sal.
My name's Jose, obviously.
I'm 13.
I'm a sophomore and an
international student.
So first, I just really appreciate you
taking the time to help us by
giving us this opportunity.
Now, my question is for
students who want to advance
more than what their
school might be offering,
what the school teaches,
the school curriculum.
And for me, specifically,
math and science.
For students who have
already taken the time to,
apart from doing the school assignments
and preparing for standardized
tests and all of that,
also taking the opportunity to participate
in extracurricular, say, online activities
such as Khan Academy, such as Schoolhouse,
for me, it's Khan Academy and AoPS
in order to advance their
knowledge for math and science,
how they might be able to communicate
to schools as well as other institutions,
the knowledge that they've
gathered on their own
using non-accredited institutions.
And you've talked a little bit about this
in some of your interviews
about how ideally,
educational institutions
could be independent
from accreditation, because that allows
mastery learning to take place
instead of just that grade mindset.
I have to get a hundred percent.
I have to get an A, right?
Just to actually take the
time to learn those concepts.
How do you communicate that to teachers?
- Yeah, yeah, you know, the good thing...
So there's two things.
One is I think if any of
y'all, there are ways to do it
even without any kind of
extra systemic support.
I remember when I was in high school,
I was going through a similar,
I was taking courses.
I was born and raised in New Orleans.
So I was taking courses at
the University of New Orleans
while I was in high
school, which back then
was actually fairly
non-standard thing to do.
And so actually, at first,
I remember them not even
letting me take the courses
'cause I wanted to take them
when I was roughly your age.
And they're like, we don't do that.
And I remember I kept going
to them and saying like,
what do I need to do to
let you take the course?
And you'd be surprised, if
you're persistent enough,
people will eventually let you.
And then I remember I
wanted to take more courses
and then they wouldn't let me
'cause there's some policy.
And then I said, well, see how I do.
So I think you can always keep pushing,
keep pushing the envelope there.
Never doubt the power of that.
The good thing is some of these ideas
are a lot more mainstream now.
And just the very fact that
you're thinking about this
at age 13 is a, sorry,
my kids are screaming in the other room.
But just the fact that you're
thinking about this at age 13,
I wouldn't worry, first of all.
But we're working on it for you, too.
So if you go on or maybe you already,
if you tutor on Schoolhouse.world
and build a strong reputation,
as I said, already two
very strong universities
are interested in looking
at Schoolhouse.world tutors.
UChicago and MIT.
And I talked to 30 others yesterday.
By the time you are
actually going to college,
I suspect we're gonna have 50
or a hundred of them that will
take a serious look at it.
I'm also working with some scholarships.
I talked to a very prestigious
scholarship yesterday.
Don't be surprised if in
the next two, three months,
Schoolhouse.world, becoming
a highly reputed tutor
on Schoolhouse.world
puts you kind of at the front of the line
for some of these really,
really good scholarships.
I'm also gonna be talking to employers.
Some of the employers
that I think many of you
all would love to work at,
where, hey, if someone is a great tutor,
highly reputed tutor on Schoolhouse.world,
why wouldn't you give them an internship?
And going back to my example,
someone can tutor Algebra,
Calculus, Statistics, Biology.
Whatever it might be, by that point,
we should hopefully have
tutoring in other subjects,
in English and in History
and whatever else by then.
Why not hire those folks?
So the good thing is you're 13.
So by that point, I will have
done more of the homework
and you'll have more opportunities
than you'll know what to deal with.
But don't be complacent, keep working.
And meditate (laughs).
- Thank you.
- Sarah, take us home.
- Hi, Sal.
You have been my role model ever since.
I used your platform even
before there was even,
just your YouTube videos even.
And now I'm a PhD student.
And I've shared those Sal Khan videos
to almost everyone that
I've met across my journey.
So I'm in awe of your work.
And I actually started tutoring on my own
because I'm motivated by you.
And then I saw Schoolhouse.world.
I started a similar
initiative in my university.
Again, inspired by you.
And I was like, oh, he
has something similar.
So I just wanted to say thank
you for all that you do.
And it really brings a lot
of joy to everyone learning.
One of the things that I
want to talk to you about
was the motto is you can
learn anything anywhere.
You hit on this previously as well.
The issue is what about these areas
where there isn't internet access?
That even in the United States,
we have these low income areas.
Now, have you ever considered partnering
with these internet providers?
Maybe creating,
I know Comcast has the
internet essentials program.
And other companies that also have
these internet access
programs and might benefit,
I mean, how do you plan on
overcoming this obstacle?
- Yeah, great question.
And something that we constantly discuss
at Khan Academy over the years.
If there is a silver
lining of the pandemic
is it's put a bigger
spotlight on this issue
than I've ever seen.
And we know for the first
time, governments and industry
and philanthropists around the world
are more serious about it
than they've ever been.
In the U.S., this latest
infrastructure around
has 60 something billion dollars
to close the digital divide,
which should go a long way.
Now, that's just the U.S.
What about the rest of the world?
The simple answer is yes.
We are relatively small organization.
We're not gonna be the people
who could put fiber in the ground.
We have lobbyists in D.C.
We can't do that kind of,
we're not even allowed to lobby in D.C.
as a not-for-profit.
But we're not gonna be the
organization that does that,
puts fiber in the ground or
put satellites in the air.
But I think the existence of Khan Academy
and Schoolhouse.world,
I think only highlights the
importance of giving access.
And access isn't just about academics.
It's even just about economic empowerment
and even social wellbeing to some degree,
as long as you can stay off
of the really bad stuff.
So we try to do what we can.
Actually, Comcast has been
one of our longtime partners.
I had a conversation with the SpaceX folks
working on Starlink.
If that works out, that's great.
That we can get more internet
to more of the world.
So yes, that's something that is,
definitely something we think about.
We have been signatories to
things with Common Sense Media
to try to close the digital divide.
And now there's talk
about the homework gap,
which is really the
digital divide at home.
But yes, we try to do whatever we can.
Now, the good news is,
it isn't happening fast
enough for any of us.
All of us would love that five years ago,
there should have been no digital divide.
10 years ago, there still is one.
But if you look at it historically,
compared to almost any
other technology ramp up,
the refrigerator,
television, it's quite fast.
So I do try to think about let's build
for where the world is going.
So I believe in 10 years,
the type of internet access
and the types of devices
that are currently fancy
I think are gonna be fairly
mainstream in 10 years.
And then if Khan Academy
and Schoolhouse.world
can sit on top of those,
then probably not
everyone's going to access.
In fact, probably the biggest barrier
for access won't be that.
It will be like governments.
It'll be like the Taliban.
It'll be government, you know.
It'll be stuff like that -
war - that disrupts people.
But economically, it should
be hopefully feasible.
So fingers crossed, but we just
gotta keep pushing on that.
- One of the things I was thinking about
maybe creating like these hubs.
Like there's a lot of schools.
Well, early in the pandemic,
there's libraries closed
or schools closed.
Maybe creating these hubs
and these, I don't know.
Again, that branding of Khan,
like these Khan hubs that
provide internet access
in these low income areas,
which obviously will have, you know,
Khan Academy and Schoolhouse.world
in the computers or whatever,
but some kind of access to
these low income areas exactly.
- You're 100% right.
We've had ideas, and
I've talked to people.
This actually is what libraries
of the future should be.
- Yes.
- I mean,
physical books have,
you know, that's good,
but people need a hub.
There's that.
I've had conversations
with major retailers.
I was just like, why don't you take
that back right corner of your store
that no one goes to right now,
turn it into a learning lab.
- Yes.
- And by the way,
parents will come, drop
their kids off there
for half an hour while they can learn
from Khan Academy and Schoolhouse.world,
and the parents are gonna buy something.
They're gonna do their shopping.
And you're giving them childcare, too.
And then they pick up their kids
and their kids would have learned.
So yeah, open to all ideas.
Museums, libraries, even big box retail.
And then in really rural places
or developing parts of the world,
you could manage a shipping container
with a internet connection to Starlink,
put a couple of low-cost devices in there,
hire someone from the village
who can just make sure
that nothing shady happens and go.
You have a school in a box, so to speak.
- Yes.
- Let's work on it.
- I was thinking
like some kind of like to-go school.
Yeah, exactly.
- That's right.
So yeah, I mean, it goes
back to what I said earlier.
There's two scenarios.
You have a school, which hopefully you do.
And then hopefully Khan
Academy and Schoolhouse.world
can make it even more
personalized, even better.
But we also wanna be the
world's education safety net,
so that no one has nothing.
And actually, the safety
net's pretty darn good.
So yeah, let's figure it out.
It's not gonna be solved tomorrow,
but it's an admirable
goal to keep pushing on.
So I will stop.
- I think you have some
great minds who'll figure it out.
- Yes, yes.
And congratulations.
Just as I told Salik
to be a donor one day,
either, depending if you
go to industry or academia,
be a donor one day or when
you get the Nobel prize.
I just want a small mention.
- Yeah (laughs).
- If not for Khan Academy,
we might not have cured this disease.
- Oh, don't you worry, Sal.
I'm donating to you already.
Don't you worry.
- Oh, very good.
- With my amazing stipend.
- I feel somewhat guilty from that.
But later on, when you're
making the big money,
then you should.
But, well, thanks everyone.
The good thing is this is a series.
We're gonna be doing this again next week.
So everyone, I'm trying
to kind of remember
the names and the faces of
people who I did not get to.
And everyone else on - Zeeshan, Vinay,
Christine, Jose A.,
Evelyn, Maive, Athena, and Connall.
We didn't get to you.
And obviously, everyone
else can ask questions, too.
So I look forward to hopefully getting
to all of your questions next week.
See you then, this was a lot of fun.
Thanks everyone.
- See you next week, Sal.
Thanks.
- Thanks, Sal.
- Thanks so much, Sal.
- Thank you.
- Thank you, thank you.
- Are you still on?
- Yeah, what's up?
- Were you the one that joined in
and let people in or is it Sal?
- It was me.
- Okay.
You're gonna do this again
or should we make a note?
- Sal, next time, is it
possible to, I guess,
give someone co-host?
To let people in?
- Oh yeah, I'll do that.
Just tell me how to do it.
- Yeah, 'cause I got
like 10 chat requesting,
like they're waiting for
people to join the meeting
and I don't have the admin access.
But it's okay, we got it now.
- Let's do that.
- I just don't wanna leave, that's all.
- Oh yeah, you're still
part of the recording.
- I'm reading all of the messages before-
- Oh yeah, that's a ton.
I think you can download
them too somewhere.
- Actually, if one of
y'all can download them.
- Yeah.
- I think there's save chat.
- The three dots
at the bottom.
Yeah, save chat.
Save it as a txt file.
- All right, thanks everyone.
See you all.
- Bye.
- Bye, everyone.